but it looks like that's
the last time that bear
will be going to Whole Foods.
Amy.
I hope you're
right about that, Fleet.
Oh, they're having a bear
of a time though, aren't they?
I can hardly bear it.
(laughing)
Oh.
Everyone's talking about
the record-setting cold
we've been
experiencing this winter
with temperatures dropping
into the single digits.
We went to Central Park
to talk to people about
how they're coping.
Well, it's been so cold,
it's just hard to do everything.
Well, not everything.
Seth, shut up.
What an adorably
cold couple.
Certainly looks like
they're going to be
keeping each other warm,
huh, Am?
(forced laughing)
Yes.
I'm sorry.
Rob, can we see those
last two people again?
Is something wrong, Amy?
Just show those
people again, please.
It's just hard
to do everything.
Well, not everything.
Okay,
that's my boyfriend.
What? I thought you were
on a break.
You sent out that email
you were on a break.
Well, he's obviously
not taking a break.
We're still live, Am.
He's not on break.
Definitely live.
Okay.
Still live.
Okay, sorry about that.
In Washington Heights
this morning,
a gruesome discovery.
An elderly woman was found
brutally murdered in her--
Is she hotter than me?
What?
Amy, get it together.
Is she hotter than me?
It's a simple question, folks.
Chime in.
We're gonna-- we'll take
your answers on Twitter.
Was that--
In her apartment.
She was brutally murdered
in her apartment.
Back to you, Fleet.
Thanks, Amy.
A candlelight vigil is
being held at the United Nations
tonight in honor of--
I mean, she's Asian,
but she wasn't even, like,
a hot Asian.
I mean, she may as well
not have even been Asian--
Five teenagers tonight
are being accused
Was she Taiwanese or something?
of a hate crime
after they were caught
spray-painting swastikas
I mean, look at this.
in the parking lot
of a local Chipotle...
Look at this text.
All of them are students
at the local high school...
He sent this not
even a week ago.
How many exclamation points
is he gonna put?
... where the teacher
said they had a history
of disruptive behavior.
Look at this.
Principal John Robbins says
that the school will be
Look at this-- Are we...
instituting new classes
that teach tolerance.
Really, we're on a break.
In other news,
Madison Square Garden will be
undergoing renovations...
Pick up the phone,
(bleep).
Pick up the phone.
... this summer.
Yeah, I just saw you!
MSG officials have said
the renovations are necessary
I just saw you on my news.
to accommodate
increasingly elaborate
My news!
live musical performances,
Yes!
many of which now include
pyrotechnics
Oh, you need time to
work on your music.
and detailed
multimedia presentations.
You weren't
trying to miss me?
You're so
full of (bleep)!
They'll also be increasing
the venue's capacity
Because you are (bleep)!
From 20,000 to 22,000.
Your dick is garbage,
do you hear me?
Mayor de Blasio
welcomed the news
I'm gonna find you,
mother(bleep).
calling Madison Square Garden
the heart of Midtown.
Bob! Am I the only
(bleep) one here?
Can't you wrangle
this (bleep)?